it appeared in some sense that the
reason i was ill was because i was
taking benzodiazepines but that isn't
why
i was ill and then i took them and very
low dose and i took that for a long time
and it helped whatever was wrong with me
and it looks like it was an allergy or
maybe multiple allergies
and then
that stopped working and so i took a
little bit more for about a month and
that made it way worse and so then i cut
back a lot and then
then things really got out of hand and
so so there was a deeper thing
oh yeah in the benzo oh yeah what can
you put words to
well i had a lot of immune my my
daughter as everyone knows has a very
reactive immune system and tammy has
three immunological conditions
each of them quite serious and i had
psoriasis and peripheral uveitis which
is an autoimmune condition and alopecia
areata and uh
chronic gum disease all of which
appeared to be elderly related and so
michaela seems to have got all of that
and so that and that i think was at the
bottom of because i also had this
proclivity to depression that was part
of my family history but i think that
was all immunological as far as i can
tell so one of the things that's
happened to me
i always noticed i really couldn't
breathe
like i could breathe about one-fifth as
much as i
sometimes
could and so i was always short of
breath and
it looks like what that was perhaps was
i was always on the border of an
anaphylactic reaction
which is not pleasant
and that's hypersympathetic activation
no parasympathetic activation i couldn't
relax
at all that's a immunological response
allergic response yeah
so anyways that was what seemed now this
i don't like to talk about this much
because it's so bloody radical and you
know i don't like to propagate it but
this diet seems to have stopped all of
that i don't have psoriasis all of the
patches have gone yeah my gum disease
which is incurable i had multiple
surgeries to deal with it is completely
gone took three years my right eye which
was quite cloudy it's cleared up
completely
[Music]
what else has changed well i lost 50
pounds and
like instantly and kept it off
you